all right let's start today with a sort
of comprehensive covid update you know
last week i told you that covid cases
were
down in the united states on average
about 20 per day from their delta peak
and
we laid out a few possibilities as to
why the numbers look that way so to
remind you the things we talked about
last week were uh vaccination is
responsible more vaccination fewer cases
okay
um some natural seasonality being
responsible even though it's not exactly
lining up with the typical flu season
that there seems to be some kind of
peaks and valleys seasonality to covid
um so many infections have gotten us
closer to herd immunity combined with
vaccination that has been suggested and
then also sort of the most nefarious
explanation is cases aren't actually
going down its reporting has become less
reliable some states maybe aren't even
being honest about cases and then at the
end of last week's segment we said well
let's wait and see if this trend
continues
the trend has continued and in the last
week the numbers have dropped even more
u.s cases per day are down now 31
percent relative to the delta peak the
delta peak was about
166 000 cases per day
we're now down to 114 000 cases per day
now this is still like a wild crazy
number uh but a 31 decline is notable
for sure
now last week we didn't know whether
deaths
were declining and what i mean by that
is that deaths tend to lag cases by
three to four weeks
and since last week we were about three
weeks into the case decline
we saw deaths level out but we just
didn't know our deaths really starting
down are they on the way down we now
have another week of data and we can see
that yes deaths are declining in the
united states
down about 11
on average from the delta peak it's not
that much but it is now
clearly the direction
uh the delta peak was about 1850 cases
per day roughly half of the 3 900 cases
i'm sorry deaths per day that we saw
at the biggest peak of the pandemic so
far so delta peak deaths peaked at 1850
down to 1650 still a horrifying
unconscionable amount of death basically
half of a 911 every single day
but you'd rather see the numbers going
down rather than up now one other thing
that
we should be looking at
uh is whether what's going on in the
united states seems to follow or track
what's happening globally if cases were
going down in the u.s but up everywhere
we might say well maybe our reporting's
wrong or maybe maybe something just
doesn't make sense because we saw you
know delta came to europe and then it
came to the u.s and things seemed to
sort of move in tandem adjusting for
vaccination rates of course
the u.s delta wave down 31 percent from
its peak
globally cases are also down about the
same about 30 percent decline in cases
globally and then very important as well
uh global deaths since the peak of delta
also declining by about
25
which you really like to see
now
within the united states
we have clearer and clearer clearer data
about the political alignment of this
delta wave we've talked about this
before and we continue to get very
interesting new data check out this
incredible graphic which i will describe
if you're not watching today this is a
plot
of covet deaths per capita against how
pro-trump or pro-biden a state was in
2020. so if a state voted biden over
trump by 20 points it's more pro-biden
than if biden won by say 10 points okay
now if you're looking at this graph you
can see that the states with the lowest
per capita death rates as of september
23 14 day average so we're talking now
in in september you see that it's the
heavy biden states with the lowest death
rate vermont massachusetts maryland
california uh to a lesser degree you
know places that are slightly pro-biden
like illinois
nevada where biden won but not by as
much
the slightly trump states are then doing
even worse in terms of covet death so
like texas for example
florida and then you get into the
absolute worst states with the highest
average per capita death rates in
september these are the heaviest trump
states we're talking about alabama west
virginia mississippi etc so as we've
said before as we've seen before in the
data we don't just say it we say it if
we see it in the data
trump voting in 2020
predicts coveted death rates now that
vaccines have been widely available for
some time and that we know how you
reduce the amount of spread this is not
really a mystery and when you look at
the united states and look at the least
vaccinated states
it's essentially all red states it's
idaho
uh west virginia
wyoming
followed by mississippi north dakota
alabama tennessee indiana louisiana you
then get to ohio which is sort of uh you
know closer to 50 50 ohio a swing state
in many elections at 54 vaccination i
think you get the picture so the overall
story here is
cases and deaths declining in the u.s
cases and deaths declining globally
vaccination going up globally and in the
u.s the states that are doing the best
are the most vaccinated states which are
biden states there's really no new
information in that sense
but this is the trend as of the last few
weeks in the united states so let's hope
it continues let's hope it gets better
everywhere and we'll report back um in
another week or so and see if the
decline continues if this decline were
to continue
in six weeks we would be in amazingly
great shape
caveat i said the exact same thing
in february
where we said if these declines
continued there would be no covet in
like six weeks that's rarely the way
that it goes so we'll continue to track
the numbers and see where we end up one
of our sponsors is magic spoon breakfast
cereal sweet and tasty like the cereals
i loved as a kid but without the sugar
or the carbs every serving of magic
spoon has zero grams of sugar only four
net carbs 140 calories and packed with
13 grams of protein perfect if you're
doing keto
perfect if you're doing low carb great
if you're just trying to reduce your
excess sugar intake and because it's
packed with protein it's great before or
after a workout magic spoon flavors
include cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter blueberry and cinnamon they're
bringing back cookies and cream they're
bringing back maple waffle you can build
your own variety box and try them all
magic spoon is so confident in the
product if you don't love it as much as
i do they will refund your money no
questions asked go to magicspoon.com
pacman the link is underneath this video
and you'll get five dollars off when you
use the promo code pacman at checkout